um
hey everyone welcome to the Stream
[Music]
how's everyone doing
we're going to be continuing with the
character from uh last time jar jar
gaunt so let's get into it
what in Merlin's name in Iraq IX fresh
nice Secret Sauce see you guys
where are we
don't believe it
hey PB J Hey Ron
hey Matthew
hey siranch
hey Johnny hey Michael
the stream got uh cut off last time so
hopefully it doesn't happen again
hello
this uh this is a separate account I
created for streaming I'm a little bit
further along in on my uh main character
but I don't have too many hours
logged
hey Lucas say Vito hey hampers hey
Oliver
Zach
Muhammad
sorry if I missed you
it can't be
the moment
who Harris played the game leave a
comment
game is definitely worth buying amazing
game
you guys are further than me
no White's Pokey oh yes of course I had
to go away out of town right when the
game came out so I'm I'm behind
stay close
after you
and keep your hands inside the cars if
you don't wish to lose them
foreign
which uh house did you choose those of
you that played it
hundreds in fact you'll see quite a few
on our way to vote number 12. as we
speak we're just beneath the main lobby
the vultures
are private entrances to the bank common
at Gringotts
I'm not sure which one we'd all choose
yet
across that bridge when I get there
my other character is Southern
but I don't know if that's my favorite
that's just my house
I've gotten uh Slytherin almost every
time I've done the sorting quiz
number
vote 12.
on your way yeah being able to Port over
all of your information from Wizarding
World is a really nice feature
if you guys uh enjoy live stream content
then please give it a like so that I
know because I don't know if this is
what you guys want
Professor still new to this style
clue you saw on the bulky
content darker it's all that same glow
the dragon's color yeah what was that we
were just wondering about that Goblin
back there he watches over the oldest
section of the bank
rare anyone go
[Music]
I turned down my volume so the Subscribe
noise should be a bit quieter
here we are
is the audio good otherwise
foreign
was accessed
stationed at my desk for hundreds of
years
in that time no one has visited Vault
12. until today
okay good good I turned it down a bit so
hopefully it's getting better
I'm gonna stream for about an hour but I
will be streaming a lot more in the
future now that the game's out so
what do you suppose we should be looking
for I'm not sure so I wonder if you're
my instructions for Vault 12 indicate
that I am to Grant access to the holder
of the key and then close the door
wait
glad to hear it Moon
certainly unexpected
expected let me think
there must be something and if you guys
want videos on the game uh covering
aspects of the game or Wizarding World
lore then leave a comment a revealing
charm no time I will absolutely Give In
To The Temptations of the dark arts
nope
Rebellion
there I saw something
and just an FYI I got a PlayStation 5 to
play this game so I am very new to
PlayStation 5 as well
usually a PC Gamer
thanks Rook
ie
thanks
this is no ordinary Vault I suspect we
will need to earn our way out of here
what do you mean on our way out do you
think this is some sort of test
I do
but to what end I can't say
stay close there will be no
disapparating if things go poorly
foreign
just bear with me one sec guys I'll be
back in a second
foreign
I haven't played very much as I said I
went away so
I went away right when it came out so I
have another profile which I've played a
bit more on what is it
[Music]
what happened
when I moved towards the globe it
suddenly formed as if the ground was
swirling about
are you all right
yes sir I'm fine
you seem to have caused the floor to
change
that statue
what statue
I see some sort of statue but only is a
reflection in the floor
there must be something to that
reflection you're seeing
beautiful
tricasting revelio perhaps Rebellion I
presume this is what you saw reflected
in the floor
it is the reflection's still there but
the statue's positions don't match
wait
when you moved the reflection turned in
the direction of the light
I haven't been sorted on this character
yet
foreign
well done
now the reflections totally towards me
it does follow the light
foreign
windows
exposure
potatoes
lumos was not the spell there
nope
foreign
professor professor that was stressful
professor are you
this isn't good
I'm really not used to the uh
Playstation controller
lumos
where am I supposed to go
what's happening
the Wisps of magic seem to be leading me
somewhere
which house is everyone in comment in or
outside of the game
that's where they're leading me I glow
again
I suppose I'm on my own this time
lumos
here we go this is stressful for me
I might die
oh we need to align these statues with
their reflections
if you die you just come back
the low stakes right now
foreign
oh no
oh I was so close
okay let's try that again
producers
foreign
oh no
okay
let me try this one more time
yeah I'm on a controller
can't see it one second
difficulty that is
foreign
yeah maybe uh
this will do
foreign
that was a bit easier
yeah I'm gonna stick to uh easy for now
until I get used to this controller
lumos
foreign
thanks for joining
[Music]
very cool
what do we have here
foreign
there you are this is my second
character
what is this place I don't know
but I found this floating above that
basin
that is no mere Basin thanks yummy yummy
that is a pencil much appreciated for
viewing memories
I wonder
I'm gonna play for about another hour
tonight
but the plan is to stream kind of once
or twice a week
and I've made this character
specifically for streaming so we'll
you'll be able to continue sort of where
we left off the last time
a jar jar gaunt
all is in place
well hidden perhaps too well
I wonder if the path we've created may
be impossible to follow
it will only be impossible for one who
cannot see traces of ancient magic as I
can your ability to see what others
cannot will not be enough possible
we are entrusting the one who embarks on
this path with Powerful Secrets with
knowledge others will do anything to
obtain yes and if we are correct Charles
the ritual wizard who completes the
trials will have proven themselves
worthy of that knowledge
and the responsibility that accompanies
it
may have done all that we can
foreign
traces of an ancient magic to be precise
absolutely yeah you've got to have a few
characters one one to go evil one to go
light
did
but could never
Miriam and perhaps George
died in pursuit of knowledge that has
been dormant for centuries
and you it seems
are the key to understanding why
we were
someone's coming
who were they I don't know but sir you
shouldn't be in there
I was right
ran Rock
seems my reputation precedes me
I was beginning to think no one was ever
going to visit raccoons walks and why
are you here
no need for those who want to learn more
about Goblin rebellions in general I've
done a video on it
bygone there have been like quite a few
of them
yeah
choose your next words wisely I I only
meant
to vote
sir I must insist I was to Grant access
only to one with the key and you did
beautiful
I have no patience for Traders
later now
where were we
giving you anything
well
perhaps your young friend here will be
more
that he is
thanks Nate
much appreciated
huh
oh
this looks familiar are you all right
fine sir
I've never seen so powerful a goblin
he seemed
holy unaffected by my magic
where are we
can't be
it seems those who set up if you guys
have specific questions about law that
you want covered from the game then
leave a comment on my latest video which
was the five mysteries of Hogwarts
come
we have a sorting ceremony to get to
uh no this is not my first playthrough
it's my second character
[Music]
but I still haven't loved many hours
do you guys think of this as Canon
you think the game should be considered
Canon
what do you think
[Music]
I know they were pretty careful not to
contradict Canon but
[Music]
yeah I'd like to think of it as Canon I
mean
it is kind of an afterthought but
foreign
ceremony
I'm do you guys think cursed child is
Canon that seems more
now I think this game is more Canon than
cursed child
that's happened this evening between you
and me of course sir
ready for the Sorting ceremony
nice guy Max
hey Sapphire Raven
Phineas Knight jealous black
prepare yourself to meet
the Headmaster
fig nice of you to join us Phineas
nigellous black ass
complications complications it seems the
goblin troubles
goblins like no time for rumors fig and
I'm rapidly losing whatever patience I
had left
if you're lucky we might still be able
to get you sorted this evening
yeah this is um I think slightly too
early for Dumbledore
[Music]
Dumbledore was born in 1881 I think and
I think this game was 18 19.
yeah so yeah scar makes that's right
he's nine
the voices are great and the music's
great
yeah Dumbledore is out there somewhere
right now nine years old
hi shayto
you come here with preferences and
preconceptions yeah grindelwald's alive
too certain
I'm looking forward to exploring
Hogwarts the voices for the character
creation though are definitely off
much can be gleaned by having an
adventurous Spirit hi Leah Leah thank
you a great deal to teach you as well
I wonder
I detect something in you
a certain sense of
I think they must have gotten someone
else to do the voice for the Sorting Hat
because I know Leslie Phillips who
voices the Hat died this year unless
they got him to do it first
hey scarmax thanks for joining
[Music]
I think we know where this selection is
going
is its ambition
I may seem single-minded but it is
important to go after what you want from
Life
interesting you've recently learned that
you possess a rare ability
I detect a growing sense of ambition
yeah I'm playing on uh Playstation Lewis
perhaps you belong in Slytherin
I think I'll take it
if you guys are enjoying the stream
please be sure to give it a like
look how evely looks as soon as soon as
he's placed in Slytherin
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and one more thing
due to the unfortunate injury on the
pitch in last Spring's final this year's
quidditch season has been canceled
thanks for watching my videos Leia
enough it's nothing I've banned flying
all together but
don't tempt me
you are here to focus on your academic
futures I'm sure you all have plenty to
do so this is serious blacks great
great grandfather I said I'm sure you
all have plenty to do before classes
begin tomorrow
quite an entrance
it's lovely to meet you I'm Professor
Weasley would you be so kind as to show
our new student to their common room I
shall see to it sir
as I was saying I'm Professor Weasley
pleased to meet you nice to meet you as
well professor as Deputy head mistress
it is my distinct honor to show you to
your common room
right this way
it's quite uncommon the entrance to this
common room is so cool it may be a bit
of a challenge
but one I'm sure you're up for
I can be quite resourceful I suspect
Ed in Conroe
yeah he's the uh the Headmaster is a
great great grandfather of serious
blacks
yeah
very well
one of the bad ones aspiration
don't know about that entrance password
but
in the morning to collect you for your
first class
thank you Professor Weasley you're
welcome I hope you enjoy your first
night at Hogwarts
sleep well
looks like everyone's gone
ahead to the common room
I think uh Umbridge was the worst
admaster or headmistress
I know it's a shame there's no Quidditch
I suppose some introductions are in
order
I think Umbridge is still worse though
oh look at this guy
can I help you
yeah
I'm Sebastian Salah welcome to Slytherin
thank you not everyone has a Ministry
escort to school he was a friend of
Professor figs who merely joined us for
the ride still impressive Dreadful way
to go poor fella
glad you and figure all right
it was Dreadful certainly but quite an
experience nonetheless interesting
perspective
how did you and fig managed to escape
it's all still a bit of a blur to be
honest
didn't mean to press you just get
yourself settled we can talk more later
what book were you reading a spell book
I picked up
has a few interesting things but not
exactly what I was looking for what does
everyone think of the oh hey
Knox
clean ocx
shout out to uh Harry Potter Theory
Germany which he runs
it was nice meeting you Sebastian I'll
let you get back to your book nice
meeting you too good luck today
I wouldn't do that if I were you
ugh not going to move there are you here
watch this
you guys uh gonna be evil or good
leave a comment
they should have listened to me
ah I know who you are you're the new
Slytherin the one who barged in with
Professor fig last night interesting
tactic on your first day taking all the
attention away from the first years
I'm Imelda by the way shame I wasn't
with you and fig I could have lured that
Dragon away my skills in a broom are
legendary
operation class was for students who are
17.
we handled it
I think you're underestimating the
nature of a dragon a broom would have
been kindling
the way I fly perhaps one of these days
I'll show you a thing or two about
flying I can teach you more than Kagawa
ever could speaking of which I'd like to
get in some time on my broom before
classes
do you have a lot of time to fly during
school I make the time there's nothing
like swerving through the spiers of the
castle and around the Quidditch pitch to
clear the mind
goodbye Imelda nice meeting you it's an
eagle
they changed the um the house colors and
the mascot for the movies
but it's an eagle
that mermaids find us that evil
Hufflepuff
ah based on all the chatter When you
entered the common room I'm guessing
you're the new fifth year
I'm ominous ominous gaunt nice to meet
you ominous Well you certainly had a
memorable arrival
well if I'm going to make my Mark here I
had to start right away
you're definitely in the right house
do let me know if I can be of any help
as you navigate your first days here
though I doubt you'll need it
of course he'd be in Slytherin he's a
he's a gaunt were you expecting to be
sourced into Slytherin most certainly my
family on my father's side are direct
descendants of Salazar Slytherin one of
the four founders of Hogwarts not
something I'm especially proud of mind
you he was obsessed with blood status a
pure blood Maniac unfortunately I think
I did a video on all methods of
Wizarding Transportation I could be
wrong
he is a wussy gaunt yeah I agree
all methods of Wizarding transportation
did I make that
maybe I didn't well
I wrote it down to make
thank you ominous very nice to meet you
pleasure was all mine don't be a
stranger
hi Phoenix
welcome
good morning if I trust you're ready for
your first day I've got a video dropping
tomorrow morning on all Wizarding
languages so it'll be up 4 pm Eastern
Time first day they're more than you
think
you'll be expected to complete your owls
at the end of the year owls
yes you
after much discussion with the
Headmaster and the department of magical
education at the ministry we've devised
something extraordinary to ensure your
success
yeah
here you are
what is it it is a Wizard's Field Guide
I'm gonna do some videos on aspects of
the game that are and aren't expected in
existing Harry Potter law you would be
wise to take full advantage of this
exceptionally valuable resource
thank you professor
but what do you mean it will keep track
of what I'm learning
perhaps seeing it in action we'll answer
any questions you may have walk with me
and we shall put it to the test
thanks alts this way
I certainly would have appreciated
something like the field guide when I
was a student using the guide will also
train you to be alert to your
Hi how
this is a Hogwarts Legacy the guide will
give
do keep up hi Zach
I'm good how are you doing why don't you
cast revelio on that lumos
hi Levi
appreciate the uh the support man
I've also got a video um history of the
Forbidden Forest which will come out uh
maybe Wednesday Thursday
I chose Slytherin because it's what I've
always been sorted into so
keep your eyes
potato
I've I've done a face reveal
I'm not gonna have my face in the Stream
just yet
thanks for the Super Chat skarmix
ah good timing perfect opportunity to
show you how to use blue flames to get
around a bit quicker your Field Guide
contains a map of the Castle open it up
and find Central Hall
so getting used to uh
playing with a PlayStation controller
I've always played games on PC so it's
taking some getting used to
and here we are quite the Time Saver
these stairs lead directly to Central
Hall
you can get almost anywhere in the
castle quickly from Central Hall
is something great Zach
Heart Of The Hive our King's Club
station so to speak
thanks for the Super Chat Leah
Leah
that should be all for now you'll be
expected to attend both charms and
defense against the dark arts
and I'd like to be sure you get to
hogsmead as soon as possible to replace
the supplies you lost on the way here
thank you Professor Weasley a lot to
absorb on a first day and you have much
to learn
happily you
'll assignments for you outside of class
you'll be up to speed in no time
earlier I'd say Professor figs succeeded
in at least showing you the basics he
did do you think that uh students should
start at Hogwarts when they're younger
or older
what happened after that awful dragon
attack
my suspicion is that there's more to the
story than her search for belongings and
an extended trip up to the castle
yeah the uh the Elder Wand has a
thestral uh tale hair core
it's Elder wood
I'm sorry Professor but I'm afraid
that's all there is to it
almost precisely what
Beacon the devil thank you thank you
your ears thank you Deborah for the kind
words yes
I'm afraid I can't take all the credit
there Professor they've a rare
aptitude for magic it seems hmm
well I'm just glad you both arrived in
one piece perfectly good boats and
carriages to Hogwarts and you chose to
fly in the path of a dragon I wouldn't
say I chose the dragon's path professor
rather unfortunately it would seem that
it thanks for the tip Thomas and thanks
for Joshie for watching the videos
to field guides map of course thank you
good luck today and remember to use your
Field Guide it will be invaluable to you
and invaluable to me as I'll be using it
to keep up to date on your progress yes
yes come and find me in my classroom
after you've attended both classes today
and I'll explain more about those
assignments I mentioned and we'll see if
we can't get you to hogsmead for those
supplies
to see you Professor I'm on a console
and no this is not my first time playing
across today this is a character made
for the streams did I hear you
masterfully evade Professor Weasley's
interrogation regarding our late arrival
I did my best
but
fairly certain she suspects that we're
not being entirely forthcoming yes well
Professor Weasley is a brilliant and
astute witch it was right to keep the
details to yourself for now we don't
know where this path we've embarked upon
will lead
it may require a bit more flexibility
with your time than she would approve of
and she may feel obliged the voice
acting of the Fig is great that would be
better left between us understood
Professor good now as capable as you are
I believe the ability you possess
obliges you to be well trained happily
you have the benefit of an exceptionally
skilled team of witches and wizards to
guide you
speaking of guides
and so that I may avoid Another Not So
subtle proof from Professor Weasley why
don't I show you the clever enchantment
we included in the field guides map
unfold it and have a look
he sounds like a robot because I put the
voice uh level all the way down the
depth of The Voice
the map is Enchanted to help you find
your way this will be incredibly helpful
thank you now it sounds like you've
quite a day ahead what with classes and
a trip to hogsmeat for supplies oh I
didn't know you could change the pitch
after the fact you'll enjoy Mr
Ollivander he's an exceptional Craftsman
and a good friend as you'll reach out
when I have more information about our
mysterious locket for now focus on your
classes and pay attention more than your
owls May hinge on the magic you are able
to master Within These Walls
foreign
ox
he runs uh Harry Potter Theory Germany
so if you speak German then you know
where to go
[Music]
huh
thank you
that's very nice of you to gift
membership Scholars
thank you
thanks Gian
looks like Hermione
a bit
hi Phantom I bend over
here
behind you hi Christian
have you met Professor yet
Shall We Begin
welcome to year five of Champs he's
dressed like uh Kingsley Chapel in your
education on the art of charmwork do you
think I am confident that we will take
hold with a passion and rigor requisite
of such a challenge right now everyone
please open your textbooks to page five
one seven hey Gremlin thanks for
watching before we begin can anyone here
tell me the difference between the
incantations of the color change and
growth charms
anyone anyone
um
I am afraid it is too late to study now
my the seven months must have really
taken a toll on you all
by the looks of it you all spent your
holidays practicing obliviate on one
another
do you even remember how to perform a
basic summoning charm
hmm
hmm well it seems that we are in dire
need of review everyone get into Marvel
a Goldman has already uh graduated
now let's put those textbooks to you
thanks guys
Dale thank you get into place now
that is not bad
you are a swift learner I see a lot of
potential but remember
straight to his head nothing without
practice
keep at it
I might just rival miss when I hear
very joins class fifth year does one act
yeah
I was thinking that we might have
ourselves a little Excursion outside for
a spot of fresh air
after me
Mecca Chad hi
I've always found that fun goes hand in
hand with Mastery as I'm sure the
Quidditch players amongst us would agree
hmm
so
what better than a bit of sport
with our prowess with the summoning
charm to the test right
yeah
so why don't we have our newest student
status of hmm
very simply cast Akio on one of the
Spheres and relinquish your charm at the
salute not the money
that's it don't lose your composure
happens to the best of us
very good points to sleep why did I get
points in playing without some friendly
competition completely failed points
a bit of a challenge
come on up
you'll be the blues just as before and
miss onai you are playing red clear
yes sir
that is how it's done
excellent but here we go
yeah I'm definitely going to be doing
some uh origin videos
hey there we go
brilliant
what's this
no
yeah I started this Channel with Star
Wars Theory so he's a partner on the
channel
[Music]
and uh just because I know a lot about
Harry Potter it does not mean I'm good
at playing games
I think we are well past interesting at
this point
I'll say
the enough chatter Focus now you you
will need it
settles it all
here
whoops not to worry
there's lots of uh extended lore that's
been written about
um and released beyond the films and the
books
what's new
ah damn
[Music]
does it not remove a point very good
both of you well done
classes dismissed gather your things
Mickelson I think they both did a good
job with Grindelwald but mads was a
little bit closer to what I expected for
him originally if I'm honest they just
both did a good job
transferred yeah
it gets easier I promise
that's good to hear it's a lot to take
in all at once to put it lightly
I remember how I felt when I first
arrived I transferred here from wagadu
just before my fourth year I've done a
video on all of the different Wizarding
schools if you guys want to learn more
about wagaru before
this may seem an odd question but is
Magic the same there as it is here
years but I did have to learn how to use
a wand when I arrived here hardly anyone
at wagadu uses one
be a dick here if I want
spells cast without a wand must be less
powerful than those cast with a wand
I find one less magic to be much more
instinctive not to mention quite
convenient if one is without their want
I must admit however that I am growing
quite fond of yeah the video covers
everything to do with uh at least
everything we know
but this game actually releases more
information on it so I'll have to do a
revised version
School of magic is the largest Wizarding
School in the world
so yes bigger than Hogwarts but it never
seemed intimidating or overwhelming to
me it always felt like home
it's nice to learn about another
Wizarding school thank you for asking
I do miss wagadu but I'm glad to be here
at Hogwarts ah I Professor Verona wants
to talk to you
that's another I think the information
on the Australian Wizarding school is
the next one that will be published
but I'm not sure when that's gonna
happen
you wanted to speak with me Professor I
did I trust your first challenge lesson
lived up to experts let's just use once
to help Channel their magic So in theory
it should be more powerful protected
I suspect that people from who you know
never use ones or probably able to
channel it just as well of course
Professor it was a challenging Match
Miss unai is always a fierce competitor
though I sense that she is a bit
distracted of late
now Professor Weasley has asked that
your professors give you instruction
outside of the ordinary curriculum
to hear from you soon regarding a
special assignment that I am preparing
for you
yeah
hello there you're the new student
aren't you
hello you wanted to speak to me some
I've been eager to meet you
day's going well you certainly seem to
hold your own in charms getting so much
praise and charms for how well I've
performed
but I'll be cocky here we go thank you
but it really wasn't all that
challenging my brother William would
tell you not to be so humble and to
trust your abilities
then again he tends to be a bit
overconfident in his
well better see to my charms homework I
find Professor ronan's lessons a bit
more challenging than you do
huh
who's this
double you've got
um
perhaps you'd be good enough to blast
each other to pieces on your own time I
get new students every year but I only
have one heberdeen blacks packet is an
homage to Hecate who is a Greek goddess
by the way 78 no doubt you've heard of
it
now you may be asking yourself how an
old woman like me single-handedly took
out the largest culturing in eastern
Wales and lived to boast about it
knowledge
to the wise age matters very little
today we will review a spell that has
saved me from Death at the hands of dark
Wizards more times than I care to
remember
levioso Leviosa a levitation charm
levioso
a surprise opponent is a weak opponent
care to defend yourself master Pruitt no
one thing I've learned as an unspeakable
is the value Molly Weasley uh comes from
the Pruitt family for those who are
unaware let's practice what we've just
been starting with something small
there's lots of Greek influence in uh in
Harry Potter
[Music]
now let's try something a little larger
I don't have a Discord but uh I might
make one
I don't know I haven't really thought
about it
if I if I do decide to make one I will
let you know
[Music]
let us begin with a basic cost
foreign
thank you
[Music]
see how the dummy deflected your cast
This Time cast Leviosa first then the
basic cost remember thanks Dakota a
surprise
now the basic cost
well done
very good but the best way to practice
is it Leviosa or Leviosa comment below
to welcome now
[Music]
you may begin
only all of myself
oh he's gone
no problem not bad for a beginner
you give as good as you get
so smug
I put you on the spot and you Rose to
the challenge points just Slytherin
thank you Professor Hackett glad to have
the opportunity to practice Sebastian
was really weak there is any indication
we can expect great things from you I
demand Excellence from my students they
are capable of achieving it and they
must achieve it a classroom duel is one
thing but battling dark Wizards or as
Evermore like Mr McCall I've actually
done a video on this
it's called wire elves enslaved they're
so powerful so go check it out so I'd
advise you to keep practicing whenever
you can
perhaps Mr sallow will have some ideas
for you again well done today I shall
reach out soon we're gonna sign off uh
pretty soon here
all right that's enough spectacle for
one day but I will be back
I enjoyed that well that duel was quite
something everyone will be talking about
it it was certainly good practice
practice felt more like I was duly an
expert didn't expect a new student to be
so Deft with a wand then again perhaps
this wasn't your first duel
in fact it was perhaps I have an act for
it be quiet if you like but I know
better magic requires intention and
talent you know
you might be a perfect fit for a certain
exclusive
dueling organization
exclusive and unsanctioned Count Me In
excellent knew I was right about you if
you want to get the most out of your
time at Hogwarts you're going to need to
break the rules now and then whether
it's joining a secret dueling club or
sneaking into the restricted section of
the library you just have to be clever
enough not to get caught thank you
Sebastian I'll keep that in mind good
pleasure chatting with you I'm sure I'll
see you soon perhaps somewhere
unsanctioned we'll see if your
performance today was sheer luck or
actual skill look for Luke and Brad will
be near the clock tower entrance
if you're interested
it's time
okay guys I think that's enough for
tonight but
um I'm back now so I should be streaming
more regularly
if you enjoyed the stream give it a like
and be sure to go check out my most
recent video and leave any comments uh
there or video requests
have a good night everyone
I'll see you soon
thanks thanks everyone for tuning in
foreign